hello everyone and welcome to a video
that's not actually a new video it's
more of an addition to the previous
video
as there are so many games being played
and i said i don't know how many of them
i will be able to show you but i really
really wanted to show you this position
now it's a position from the game
shakira mamidara versus daniel dubov uh
and here as you can see mama jarov is up
two pawns and being up two points in an
end game is uh
well always winning there i mean of
course there are positions where it's
not but
unless it's one of those weird positions
it's always winning
and this is also one such position that
is winning however
now you still have to play the the
absolute best moves now
how this game continued it's something
out of this world
uh so uh check this out uh so it's
on the move it's move 63 already
actually in my media
plays rook to b6 uh sorry about that he
wants to chase away the bishop and then
start pushing his past pawn dubo goes
bishop the c2
and now rook the e6 with check we have
kinked the d7
and now rook the e7 with check and this
is all perfectly fine we have king to c6
and now bishop to e5 now mamiyar is
threatening rook to c7 check and he
wants to win the bishop on c2
but this bishop the e5 move actually
allows duba
uh to create a a miraculous save
of the game uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to find
the only move that forces a draw
in the position while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding an
absolutely brilliant idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the idea is
rook to f1 you have to give up the
bishop on c2
as crazy as that sounds this is the way
to go and now there is no way
for whites to defend the f5 pawn if you
just allow rook captures on f5
then you're up only one pawn bishops are
of opposite colors you're not really
going to be able to win this so here
uh mamidarov went for the bishop there
really isn't a better move
rook the c7 check and now came to d5 so
the bishop is lost
but this is where the magic happens uh
rook captures on c2 was played and now
dubo of course played uh well you all
know what duplo played here
he played rook captures on f5 he
sacrificed the rook and
this allows the black king to remain in
stalemate
king captures and f5 was played it
doesn't matter what you play here
because uh well even if you don't
capture the rook it's not going to help
you if you just move
the move the king is still just rook
captures on e5 and this is now a
draw the extra pawn doesn't mean
anything the white king is too far
so here mommy daryl saw what happened he
captured the rook on f5 and here uh
it's a draw by stalemate because the
king and bishop prevented the king from
reaching any of these squares and the
rook completely cuts off the king from
the c
file and that means the black king has
nowhere to go
so really really incredible stuff and i
was well everyone of course shared this
i was very amazed when i saw this i
didn't see it yesterday because i wasn't
following the games yesterday i only saw
it today
so i wanted to share this with you guys
and uh well i i did not find uh
enough time to show you the entire game
uh but at least
something so really really impressive
stuff uh hope
uh hope many of you found it as this is
uh not something you you see every day
to
if i mean you have to to achieve
stalemate you of course have to
have no moves but to sacrifice two
pieces in two moves that's just uh
awesome
so yeah really really impressive stuff
by double and uh and what an
excellent save so like i said we're
going to discuss the standings of the
tournament
after i show you one more game uh and
then we are going to
well uh cover uh the the games of day
two
so basically that's what i want to show
you hope you guys enjoyed it and that a
lot of you found it
uh i would like to thank uh quang peter
dang uh corey talley boncloudchess.com
henry alma and scott melis for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the melt
water uh championship checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day